all right let's get into some other
stuff there's been so much negative news
during the vacation which of course we
continued producing shows during with
guest hosts that I wanted to do a couple
others sort of like insider David Pakman
show things that are going on one of
them which i think is going to be of
interest to many people is that I was
going to do a segment today announcing
that I'm going to be at politican this
year debating and on panels and
politican is this big political
conference as the name suggests where
they do debates last year
Genki Gore debated Ben Shapiro and I
don't remember any of the others but
there were lots and lots of different
debates that went on and I was invited
to participate this year and I was
hoping to do an announcement where I was
going to say I'm going to be debating
and here's what I'm doing and you should
go and check it out now unfortunately
number one I don't yet know what I'm
going to be doing I'm still waiting to
hear what I'm going to be doing during
the October 20th the twenty first
conference which is in Los Angeles but
the other thing is that I am now under
increased pressure to not participate
okay and the way that this started is
that there was some controversy because
initially politican had invited Milo you
Napoles to participate I don't know in
what capacity he was invited
then it was announced that Milo you
Napoles had been dropped from politican
and Milo said I don't care and that was
sort of maybe it but it wasn't it
because a bunch of prominent articles
were written afterwards saying that
aside from Milo this is a toxic event
this isn't an event where debate happens
that is going to further the discourse
or get us to solutions about issues
around which we disagree the articles
written said this is going to be an
event with the worst type of sort of
talking point yell over each other
format of debates now that's true with
some debates and not with others if you
look at the debates from previous years
and and I think that really depends more
on the individual person that that's
debating my idea all along has been
similar to that of my
appearing on fox news yeah maybe the
format's not the best one what I can do
is show up and do the best I can make
the best possible case I can make for
the ideas I believe in whatever the
subject matter would be if the event
will in total not be good for the level
of discourse which is a fair criticism
it won't be made worse by me showing up
that's sort of the same idea that I
applied to the Fox News appearance the
counter to that would be if everyone who
had a reasonable head on their shoulders
refused to participate there would be no
event it would implode and maybe
whatever damage the event does wouldn't
be done so what's the argument in short
it's that me refusing to attend simply
because there might be bad actors in the
lineup or the format isn't the best one
what will actually be accomplished by me
doing that so I want to hear from you
about this because I've received and I
was surprised because the announcement
about my participation came like the
last day before I left on on vacation
and so I assumed that until I announced
that on the show maybe not that many
people would hear about my participation
a ton of people heard about it and I've
already received more than a dozen
emails saying David you you really
shouldn't participate because you are
participating in something that is
destructive to what it is that we are
trying to build as a movement of
progressives who like to talk about
things sort of rationally and reasonably
so I want to hear from you about this
are there people who vehemently disagree
with that point of view are there others
who agree is there's some other approach
that I should be talking about in sort
of analyzing this I will definitely
follow up and I want to hear from the
audience about your thoughts because the
pressure is mounting on me to not
participate in at politican and I've
talked to Sam cedar about this I've
talked to Kyle kolinsky about this both
of whom are also going on the line up so
send me your thoughts I want to hear
from you